Paris was prepared for riots but the
morning started quite unexpectedly a
massive explosion in a bakery in the
center of the city I've counted at least
five stretchers being rushed down to the
scene three of them to come back to with
people on there who are obviously
seriously injured there's a hotel here
treating the wounded walking wounded
whatever happened whatever the cause of
the explosion
it was clearly huge three died including
two firefighters and dozens were injured
the city's emergency services already on
edge reacted fast and in big numbers at
first not sure what had caused the
explosion I heard big explosion and then
a lot of pressure came out on me so a
lot of black smoke and glasses and I
just have time to get down and cover
myself and to get my head so I feel a
lot of things they follow up on me and
then I cover my head so a lot of smoke
and demon and I was in the French Prime
Minister and Interior Minister were on
the scene within the hour
[Applause]
by mid-afternoon the focus had shifted
as anticipated to the sean's alizée and
a ninth weekend of violence protesters
dug up the cobbles of one of the most
famous streets in the world and use them
as missiles
the police hit back with water cannon
and tear gas it's a small hardcore group
who intent on confronting the police but
even that small group it's probably a
few hundred strong in fairness most of
the protesters the other side of the art
trail just watching what's going on
police encircled protesters around the
octave trail what do you think of this
image of Paris there's one of the city
and for nine weeks now it's been well
that's what the polls in the state that
are trying to make the image of us
they're trying to make to make an image
of us fighting but the thing is they
were authorized to be here we have the
right to be here
so for yet another weekend in Paris one
of the most visited cities in Europe was
in chaos president macrons government is
being severely tested and images like
this are not helping our sparkle Sky
News in Paris